Film Courage: Mark your new book A Screenwriter's
Journey to Success,'  I understand from
what you told me off camera took you
five years actually write it? Mark Sanderson screenwriter, author: I did. I
didn't sit down to write a book.
Initially I was blogging and I wanted to
get my past 20 years of professional
experience amount out of my you know
mind and heart and try to be able to
share it with people and so after five
or six years of blogging I realized that
I had enough information to you know
create something and so I started the
process of stripping down the articles
and reef fabricating them into you know
into chapters and and that I thought
well I'm gonna chart my journey from how
I started in the business as a filmmaker
at 11 years old you know what what was
that spark that creative spark and
charted all the way until today and not
so much as a memoir but also using
examples and funny anecdote old stories
but you know disciplines that I've used
that have helped me you know stay in the
game that hopefully other other writers
would be able to see and go oh yeah I'm
not doing that or I need to do that well
you referenced a friend's grandfather
gave him a camera when you were both
around 11 and that sparked her love for
making movies together have you ever
thought about what if that hadn't
happened oh yeah
I I'm not I'm sure would have been some
I should have I would have gone into
some creative endeavor I wanted to be a
cartoonist originally because I loved to
draw and I still do and in the book
there's um when I was writing the book I
drink a lot of coffee and so it would
leave a coffee ring you know on the
notes and so I would do little doodles
and I've turned those into coffee ring
mugs and t-shirts and things like that
but they're also in the book after every
chapter and so I wanted to be a
cartoonist or an animator or something
creative and but yeah filmmaking I don't
know if he maybe my parents that my
parents eventually bought me my own
camera but I don't know you know it's
it's interesting I think about it that
there's the
times in your life that you know it you
you only can look back on now but I
don't know it'd be interesting what I
would do something creative absolutely I
was not gonna be a doctor
you know why not did that you know I was
not gonna have a day job I was gonna do
something creative so I knew that
because my parents were always very
supportive of my brother and myself in
the creative arts and my brother is a
graphic designer
and you know he's always had the ability
and talent for art and so my parents my
dad wanted to be a singer and he came
out to Los Angeles from Michigan in the
early 60s and he would sing in the piano
bars and he recorded you know little 45
records you know and he wanted to be a
singer and that was his creative thing
but I always saw him doing poetry and
and drawing and you know things like
that and my mom was artistically
inclined with jewelry making and so I
came from creative parents but they came
from an era where their parents didn't
support them you were gonna get a job in
business or you were gonna go in a
factory it was just very clear-cut and
so I think they wanted to break that
mold and really supported my brother and
I for that and that's so important and I
in the book dedicate the book to my
parents because without them there would
be no support system you know that's
vital I think that's that's beautiful
was there a blog post or a chapter in
the book that was actually difficult for
you to write cuz I know it's a
combination of these blogs that you did
over a five-year period right but was
there one that you actually thought oh
this is fine and then you realize you
know this is this is actually affecting
me Oh interesting
yeah I think going back to the period
the the slow periods and in one's career
or having having achieved something and
not have the results that you think you
know like well look I I sold a movie I
should be this and the reality is well
no that's not always the case after I
sold my first
it was my fifth spec but it was my first
spec that I sold I was at the time doing
catering because I had worked in
restaurants before I went to film school
and after you know because I always
didn't want to get into a day job where
I would not have any time to write and
so restaurant was good money and it
would free you up to be able to write as
long as you would write because that's
important I was in the restaurant with a
lot of people wanted to be actors and
they they loved playing the role of an
actor but not actually doing the work so
if you're you're given the free time to
do it you better do it and I always did
it you know so but it was the time when
I sold my spec and I was in the trade
papers in a variety and every writer
wants to be in variety right then you
say oh I made it right well the day that
I was a variety the headline was this
new company had formed and they they
option my script and they were going to
buy it and make it into their first
movie and that day and variety I had to
do a catering job had one of the biggest
producers in Hollywood's house and so it
was his catering company and my friend
and I drove up to Beverly Hills and here
we're at this giant mansion of this
producer and it was a big breakfast
meeting with big pop you know power
players former prime minister of a
Middle Eastern country you know security
everywhere and I was thinking wow you
know I'm in variety today why should I
be catering you know and also I was
thinking in a way which is in the book
what if this producer had had you know
rejected my screenplay Here I am in his
house serving him coffee you know so
just be careful about who you you know
disrespect you know on the way up or
down because he you know the you just
might end up in your in their house
pouring coffee for them you know but
that was hard to write but hey I look
back on that now and laugh you know but
it's it's a reality of the business
because as you know you know it's a step
deal so and have anything sells you know
it's in steps and you may not get the
final steps so when a screenplay sells
you get a little bit of
and then a little bit of money for the
next draft and next and that has to be
made for you to get the bonus so
everyone thinks that just because a
script sells suddenly you're you know
everybody's calling on the phone and
things like that so I would say that was
not difficult to revisit but you know I
think about the time I put myself back
into the time that's all I was trying to
do when I was writing because I'm a very
visual person and I can really have this
sense of memory and the back in the time
it wasn't funny you know it was very it
was like oh my gosh so now I've done
this and still I have to do this and
you're like yeah many times you have to
live in these two these two parallel
worlds and that can mess with your head
a lot so you have to be really ground
and say this is the reality of it and it
doesn't it doesn't it's not the image of
Who I am I am a writer if I'm catering
or always doing anything else at the
time you know so you know that I think
that's such an important story because I
think people can be caught in two worlds
here for years
absolutely and eventually some will
definitely turn the corner and and the
the party will be at their house yes Oh
speak to use that metaphor and
unfortunately for some it won't so
advice to people on being caught in two
worlds because the reality of being here
is that that may be the case for a
decade for some people maybe even more
and at some point they will cross over
and they'll be hosting parties and for
some it may not happen but on keeping
your mind right and and keeping your
work ethic right well that's that's
difficult I mean it's like it's like
training I used to run you know there as
a runner and that that discipline of
that constant was really important you
know and I would run no matter if I was
tired and it's that same work ethic that
you need is writing because they see so
many writers who say uh-huh and it's
difficult I understand I tell some some
writers say oh I just did a 10-hour day
in there like ten hours ago we'll have
to because I have an assignment and it's
due and
and I have the luxury that's my job
thank God
you know now when I had a day job only
once in my life for two years I worked
at a law firm I had to come home from a
full day work I was an assistant and
then at six o'clock make dinner and then
right until midnight and then go to bed
7 a.m. go to that job there was having
two jobs at once and then on the
weekends people would say oh come on do
this and that and I said well I have to
write write what are you talking to my
said well and it was it was terribly
exhausting and I can see how it can chip
away you know and at you especially if
you have a family and a lot of different
concerns pulling at you that's why you
have to really close the door and say
this is my time and had it cannot be
interrupted and that it is hard to do
but you really have to stay discipline
and also I think you have to have the
fire and burning passion to really want
it more than anything else because you
know I never I never put an expiration
date on my dreams and I remember people
saying well it was a dinner one time
friend of my brothers and he said well
what if you don't make it by 30 and it
was like 30 and I said well I don't know
what's 30 and they ut2 him he was
projecting his fear upon me and I go hi
this is open-ended you know I'm sorry
but you know and that's good and bad
because you don't want to fool yourself
like you're saying we're 10 years and
you have nothing I mean I think at a
certain point if you've really exhausted
all of your abilities and nothing's
happened you might consider something it
may be writings not for you maybe this
pursuit of a career is not for you and
it's a choice no one's forcing you to
write screenplays it's a dream you know
is my dream since I was 11 years old so
am I going to achieve it am I going to
achieve it at a level that I want
because I like when I worked in the
restaurant while I was going to film
school I I knew people or actors they
said well it's not worth it for me if
I'm not like Brad Pitt and I said oh
really
so you think you're just going to fall
into it and be a list now most working
actors or
you know the the co-star character
actors work all their lives the leading
person leading man leading woman have to
carry the film and how many you know I
mean it sorry I just you looking at it
it's like and Plus as you as you get
older you you you look at it differently
and you say well I'm I'm blessed to get
up in the morning and do what I love for
a living and get paid for it and and see
it you know see it end up somewhere and
people respond to it negatively or
positively that's it you know yes
continue to strive for more and other
projects and different things but it's
hard and but the important thing too is
to have people around you that support
your endeavor because I've lost
friendships and I've lost relationships
with people who said well and they drew
a line in the sand and they said and I
was like well it's not a good thing to
do and what about the last X number of
years I've been doing this you're just
gonna throw help me throw that away you
know the the lack of understanding about
how much filmmaking and writing was such
a part of my being almost that other
creative endeavors like drawing and
things like that but but this is like
Who I am and to have someone with you
not understand that it's really you know
and that's the hardest part that so many
elements just like in making a film so
many elements have to go together and
all click the same way with forging a
career and as you've interviewed many
different people everybody will tell you
a different story about how they
quote-unquote made it and I was doing a
seminar recently and someone asked the
question about making it and I said well
I think I don't know if you ever make it
I said I think getting your next job is
making it and continuing to stay in the
game is making it you know there's
nothing guaranteed if you're on a TV
show the show's gonna end then you have
to get up and we're like gypsies find
another job I have a movie shooting
right now in Los Angeles when that ends
I mean luckily I have a few things
already going set up you know job wise
you have to find your next job you know
it's just it's just the case but after
it's it's difficult but
you know no one said it was gonna be
easy before we wrap up on this topic I
just want to ask going back to that day
that you're working this shift at
wherever it was the top of Mulholland or
wherever it was Beverly Hills okay and
you're you're let's suppose so you've
you've broken down the event you're
driving down this mountain or wherever
it may be not a mountain what's going
through your mind
your name's and Friday why I stopped at
the newsstand before the job and picked
up a pile of varieties you know because
you have to and reread it and I wasn't
on the cover the company was on the
cover but I wasn't like peach thirteen
with a paragraph how they discovered me
right so it's so you know it's so nice
to be discovered and I'm here you know
pouring coffee for you know these people
it was it was freak because there was a
fear that like that was like somehow was
a big fraud and and it was never gonna
happen even though it was terrible I
mean it was it was hard to to really
lock in and then you get home and it's
like very depressing they're like
there's no crowd cheering there's no II
like Wow but then being pragmatic saying
well I have to pay bills and there's no
embarrassment about doing a job that you
have to do because that job allowed me
to continue to stay in the game now yes
the the movie was optioned but as movie
options goes there's not for a lot of
money sometimes and so and then the
movie developed 18 months it was in
development with me so you're talking
about and that script was seven years
after I wrote it so it took seven years
from when I finished it to when it
finally found the company and was made
not all scripts happen that way you know
but I'm talking about a spec and so this
long process with a lot of fear that can
be involved but yeah it was it was you
know but I always look back on these
stories not at the time maybe and say
this will be a good story for the book
someday or to tell someone you know how
these things happen you know there's a
reason why I think we go through
everything is to either learn something
and if we do maybe pay it forward and
saying hey you know and that's kind of
like my reasoning for the book
is to try to pay it forward and saying
you know I went through all these crazy
knocks and these pitfalls and you will
too maybe more maybe less but maybe if
you'd zig and zag and it'll help you a
little easier you know but it's all
difficult for all of us because we also
have to sit in front of the blank page
you know that's where we're equals
i screenwriters you know but we had a
comment that came in that said well
that's easy for this person to say
because this person is a professional
screenwriter and it's their job to write
all day it makes sense to say it's your
job kind of like get over it just do it
but most people that watch the film
courage channel it's very nice that they
thought that are not professional
screenwriters they actually have jobs or
other jobs have to pay the bills
screenwriting is a hobby for them at
best while they sort of make the two
worlds work sure and that I get so no
you don't have to write every day to be
a writer I don't write every day I do
when I'm on assignment and then when I'm
not I'm kind of exhausted and the last
year has been crazy I mean with like six
movies so it's like almost every three
months to turn around so I'm calm I
would but it's fantastic because I was
constantly writing but it's it's it's
draining it's almost like I want to go
do something else and stop and they said
well when you stop the assignment you
want to go work on your spec so not
right now because I don't have the time
you know and and but you have to manage
your time you know you really do and
there's no excuse I've had to do it when
I was in college in film school I was
working four to five nights a week in a
restaurant but I had friends who went to
film school or any college and they
could just go to school they had the
luxury of living at home their parents
paid for everything I had pay my bills
you know but I think that that trained
me into really sectioning my time not
just you know because yeah you can go to
parties and all this stuff and I was not
only making movies in the film school
but I was also after day class I had to
go down I was working in Westwood here
and work a five hour shift and then come
home so really trained me for that and
there's a million excuses why we don't
want to write
I mean truthfully it's and when it's
difficult even more oh well you know
like I said I never have the house is
never as clean as when I'm you know get
procrastination but you know again the
movie I just turned in last week and
assignments my 35th screenplay I'm it's
still learning I still respect the craft
and bow down to it because I learned
something every time out every projects
different every producer company you
work with it's a whole different
scenario each time yes you know you know
how it works a lot better I look at old
scripts now and like my fourth spec my
fifth one sold the fourth one made some
noise we met with the a-list you know
actor about it as a million years ago
but I look back at that script and I was
like ah if we'd only if I could only go
back and rewrite that with what I know
now but you only have the knowledge that
you have at this exact moment in time
and you can't live with regrets so study
get better write more screenplays
but yes writers right but I don't think
you should feel guilty if you're not you
know writing every day but don't let it
go two days because two leads to four or
four leads two week this weekend we got
something going on you have to schedule
it and I always say to aspiring
screenwriters treat it like your job
because it will be you don't have the
luxury of when you write your specs to
go uh I'm gonna go off today work on it
for five minutes ten minutes whatever it
is but that constant is what's gonna
happen when you get the assignment jobs
and you know you don't want to be
shocked when suddenly you get this
opportunity you're hired to write a
movie and you can't physically sit there
for eight hours a day or you can't write
it in 30 days or you can't write it in
eight weeks or however much time you've
agreed to write the screenplay you will
be shocked because you're not training
the same thing as an athlete or you
wouldn't you wouldn't go run a marathon
without training for it same thing and
in my opinion and in my experience and
so if you're gonna spend the time
writing your specs train yourself now
for the
hopefully hopefully the time that you're
gonna be hired to write screenplays and
then you'll be much better but again yes
you know coming from a thing that that's
all I do for a living but that's where
you want to be and and like I say I
better I better damn well be doing it
you know ten hours a day if that's all I
do
and it seems like maybe some jobs are
more draining than others and I know
it's easy for me to just say oh well
just find a job that's not draining and
I know that's easier said than done but
I think there's certain jobs where you
can then have sort of a side other job
or slash hobby and then there's other
jobs where it just takes you out of it
it's so demanding and the thing about
that is it's gonna take you that much
longer if you can only write on the
weekends how long do you think a
screenplays gonna take it's gonna take
six months you know I mean that's where
the time creeps in and there's so many
other distractions and interruptions
that come in that six months that are
dangerous that will derail you so
quickly and then go hmm you know that's
where that's where you have to do I I
would dig deep and say this is what I
want to do and there's nothing I mean
that's sort of the passion and the
tenacity come from that really drives
you through all those other you know
through the minefield you're gonna step
on that pool you know they set you back
three months you know it's really um
it's difficult and yes you're right
other job when I had worked at the law
firm for two years it was draining and I
would come home and then have to write
again but I had I had a move and it was
even worse because I had a movie go into
production while I was at the job and
again it wasn't enough money to quit and
so I said I had to excuse myself and say
I'm gonna go to the set for a few days
this week because I was a as needed
assistant type of position and that was
again even years later the freaky thing
going but why do I have to work at the
thing I got a movie in then you look at
the you know okay I get it and then I
stayed on it for another year at the
firm and do the same thing come home
make dinner right you know bubble blah
and then I got a call from the
production
and work with and they have a new
president production and they said hey
how come we haven't worked with you
since the last movie I said I don't know
they said we have this fast track movie
we want you to write it's a it's a done
deal and I gave my two-week notice Wow I
was like this is my kick in my pants
that I'm back in without fear not like
oh well and the money was good at the
firm you know but I was seeing myself be
derailed and I had a relationship at the
time my girlfriend and I saw just
everything was being derailed and I
thought well I could just get into this
and you know another year go by and so
when that call came in from the company
I was like I gotta go and they were
shocked they were like well well I guess
this is what you do I said yeah this is
what I do I'm a writer I have to go do
writing and it's a job so yeah I said
you're always welcome to come back I
said exactly but like when I finally
quit the restaurant business when I got
my first job it took six years out of
film school before I landed my first
professional writing job and I thought
when they handed out the diplomas they
were gonna give me a to picture deal you
know oh thank you very much oh look at
this six years and that's not for lack
of writing and specs and all that stuff
a finally landed a job so I gave the
notice at the restaurant and they were
like huh they didn't quite understand
and they were like so and how long is
this job for I go no I'm out o UT not
coming back I said I appreciate there's
never again while I step foot and I
didn't I mean I did catering but that
was sort of like less of a you know your
different places but I was never gonna
work I worked ten years in a restaurant
I did many odd jobs in my life I say in
the book many different jobs that you
have to but it was all about
facilitating me being able to stick with
my dream whatever whatever the job was
at law as long as it allowed me to
continue I didn't care you know was an
embarrassing or you know it was just
like you have to do what you have to do
reminds me of the movie I just watched
It's a Wonderful Life
so Jimmy Stewart just gets he just
thinks I'm gonna you know go off and see
the world then go be an
detect and then get sucked back in for
two years or four years at the bank and
you know you know and it just it keeps
life changed for him it's hard you know
it really is hard yeah but I as I say
it's hard I'm living proof that it does
happen and there's no guarantees but I
always say the only guarantee in
screenwriting is that you should stop
writing
you're definitely guaranteed never to
have any chance at success
so as long as you're in the game you
have a shot from what I saw in your book
on Amazon when I was going through you
said that you didn't have relatives in
the industry you had very supportive
parents and you had to break in what you
call the old-fashioned way which was
hard work discipline and faith and I was
wonderful you talk about the faith part
what is that exactly is a if you don't
believe in yourself why why do you
expect other people to believe in you
and it's your dream someone else will
live their dream and why shouldn't you
live your dream that was always my
opinion and it's scary because you don't
know if you're going to or they will
allow you to do it
so you have to write something that you
care about but also that somebody else
sees you know that care in there and
wants to make it and then the business
part becomes they want to invest
millions of dollars and your idea as
opposed to somebody else's idea and it's
finding that company it's the timing
finding my spec sold because my first
and only spec which was my fifth spec
but that opened the door for assignment
work so I haven't sold a spec since then
because I've been blessed with
assignment work which is fine I've
written other specs yes but it's
exhausting to try to continue you know
this one and maybe this one it's much
you know it's it's a much better
experience when the producer comes to me
and says are you available we have this
concept that's greenlit we need a writer
you're like thank you very much you know
I I would love the job I'm available and
I've turned down stuff as well but the
faith aspect you always have to have
faith
not blind faith but there are times when
you're staring into that dark abyss and
you go I'm gonna take the leap you know
like when I worked a day job at the law
firm you know I only had a day job for
two years in my whole life you know I
worked other odd jobs like restaurants
and things but once I was I decided to
take that day job because things were
really slow in my career when I got the
call from the production company and
they said we have this job we want to
get back in business with you I took
that leap now wasn't the void wasn't so
dark because it was a job it was money
but I could have thought about it and
said well I'll stay at the firm because
it's steady money and I'll do this other
job you know and I can do both right
because I have and it wasn't worth it
for me to do that I was really young the
minute they said hang up that phone a
tree week notice I took that leap
because I just need to do that I have to
live the life of a writer you know and
and luckily the ex lasts X number of
years I've been able to do that live the
life where I get up and that's the only
thing I do that's my job
and it's you know the faith aspect like
I said as we discussed before you always
have to have people who believe in you
but that only goes so far they can all
yeah you know right you're the best you
know oh that's why I say don't give your
script to your family members to read
because unless they're executives and
Warner Brothers because there's no real
point in it you know everybody's gonna
say there's the best thing ever
well it kept my interest you know if
you're great so everybody can rally
around you and say yeah and have the
faith but it comes down you're living
you're living it you know you're sitting
in front of the computer you're trying
to come up with ideas and your your
choices that you make are directly
affecting your life financially and
psychologically and you know
relationship wise with other people so
there's a lot of things involved about
pursuing a screenwriting career not just
oh I'm gonna write a script
you know there's a bigger picture about
how it affects you to life especially
when it becomes how you pay your bills
so faith is an important part but you
have to there's always a fear still I
mean when I get a new job I get nervous
you know I think I read that the Henry
Fonda would throw up on stage before he
went out to do a performance you're like
you're Henry Fonda but I think a little
of that nervous not too much fear but
that like respects that's where the
respect for me comes into the craft
where I sit down I go and my mom Oy says
oh you'll know what to do you're fine
you know to this day she says that I go
I think I'm fine but I I'm pretty sure
I'm fine and then yeah I finish it and I
go yeah okay but I don't want to have
that arrogance of like all working in
this is fine no no no absolutely not so
um I have a tremendous faith in my
ability but I temper it with humility
and also the realities of the business
and and you know just situations I guess
so faith is the back your question is
extremely important but I think it faith
in yourself first and foremost don't
search outward for it you know like
looking looking for validation from
outside to get that you know like oh
I'll write something and if somebody an
agent likes it then that validates me
you know know know and have faith in
your abilities first and foremost and
then go out there and see what happens
that's gratitude always been a part of
your makeup I see that gratitude seems
to be a strong thing for you but maybe
I'm wrong has it always been in your
nature mean gratitude
seems like you you recognize yes well
also the longer you're in the business
you you it always has been my makeup yes
but the longer you get punched around
and and see how things work for myself
everybody has a different story
you you're very humbled and gracious and
then you say things like I'm blessed yes
I feel that I blessed but I also have
done a lot of hard work and a tremendous
amount of sacrifice in my life to devote
to this and not for the sake of being
you know the wealth and the riches and
the loot you know because there is no I
say there's no fame and fortune in the
screenwriting game I mean you know it's
it's when you have most half of the
writers in the writers guild
don't don't work every year and those
are professional WG writers I think the
odds last year like 5,000 200 or
something out of approximately 10,000 so
the other half are looking for jobs and
not working you know or the 50,000
scripts there apparently registered with
the guild every year those are just the
ones registered or the 70 to 100 specs a
year this sell you know I always tell
writers I don't bring up those odds to
scare you but for you to realize what
you're up against you know you wouldn't
go climb Mount Everest without the
training and the help and the tools you
just go okay I'm gonna go do it now
there's a certain courage in doing that
but there's also a certain stupidity at
some time you know and just like writing
your script and being eager and someone
says oh I want to read and you give it
to the wrong person and then that bad
note circulates you're finished you know
I mean they're things like that so yeah
with this job at the law firm so you got
this movie or you got some other show or
something
did you did that pan out no it was made
it was me okay I went to the set while I
was working and that was the that was
the hardest part where I'm like I don't
want to go back and then I had to go
back he even you know but I'm like I'm
deja vu I'm back in the situation I was
however many years before with with you
know doing the catering when I sold my
first spec because the way monies are
doled out in the step deal you just
because it's option or whatever it
doesn't mean you can quit your job and
live in Bel Air you know so there's the
realities about paying your bills so
it's same thing when I was working at
the day job but again I was like it
starts to psychologically work and you
say no but I'm a writer it's a yeah you
work at a thing
back in the tunnel again I'm you know
and there was another writer there who
was a sitcom writer and he had worked on
things and he too had a short thing and
you know short I mean a young a slow
period and he was he was on his way to
get back too and he did too we all sort
of quit at the same time and he got back
in their writing sitcoms and I was like
yeah you know no looking back and I
don't know it's just there's now again
you know I I don't have you know
children you know so I you know that
family aspect is a whole different you
know thing so what I say is from my own
opinion that means from my own
experience but it sort of it sort of
goes for everyone you know with with
disciplines and things you have to
really keep your eye on the prize and
the big picture as I say because you can
get lost so easily even when you're in
it and doing it you can get lost you
know so you always have to have to have
that bigger plan but where am I going
with my career what am i doing you know
is it crucial to have multiple projects
going at once yes why because like
salmon going upstream a few will get up
there I mean you you have one scripts
not going to do it as I always say one
script eventually does open something
like for me my spec opened the door for
assignment work with the company you
know I continued on with that but if you
just focus your energy on one thing it's
it's a it's a lot it's you know the odds
that it's gonna get you you have to be
constantly then that was my problem I'll
share with you when I sold my spec I
didn't have a follow up and that would
that really was a problem because I
thought Here I am and there was no
follow-up for a while and that was my
mistake
because I didn't have I wasn't thinking
in those terms you know was early on and
might pursue you know I just did
graduated from college and you know was
not thinking and that structured like
okay this is what's my game plan here
and I knew a friend who went to film
school and he directed a movie that he
wrote but he didn't have a follow up
they spent so much time on this movie it
was a feature
and he didn't sell it it didn't get
picked up by anyone he paid money to
show in a theater and they okay
what else you have nothing you know so
you constantly as I say in the book you
have to have ideas that you have to have
log lines that you're working on then
you also have to have some treatments or
one-sheets which are a lot easier to do
than write a complete screenplay and
then you also have to have your
screenplay that you're working on but
constantly when you go into a meeting
with your spec that gets you the meeting
they're not buying that spec they just
want to meet you say oh I can see your
ability and then they say what else you
have and you don't want that to be well
I'm working on something and it's gonna
take me six months I'm not gonna see you
for six months or you're not gonna be on
my radar for six months you want to say
I have this other thing you don't want
to bring you know a suitcase full of
scripts but you want to say I have this
other thing oh well after the meeting
send it over BAM
you know I mean you you have to have
multiple projects in the marketplace I
think at all times because not all of
them and maybe not one of them but the
that's what you're up against it is to
be I don't want to see a machine but you
you know you can't be precious with I'm
only working on one thing for five years
and and you if you have the luxury of
doing that that's great
but you better have a day job to pace
you know if you're you know I didn't
want to wait tables the rest of my life
you know
so what motivated me to get out was
continuing to write and create you know
so yeah I think it takes more than one
project you know I know you do a lot of
speaking events this hour I do yeah so
when you have writers approach you
either afterward or even if you see them
at a mixer or something and you know
when people ask you for advice and you
give it and you can see that they're
disengaging because they don't want to
hear the answer yes what are some of
those points when you're talking they're
saying hey how do i how do I break into
the industry is there their experience
will be different than mine which it
will be but their experience will be
like oh it's not going to happen to me
like I said mobray projects in the
marketplace you know and so when people
do that I just say
I don't want to expend any more time
bestowing any sort of advice you know
because what's the point if you're gonna
example a friend I did a favor for a
friend I said oh my friend wrote this TV
pilot okay I'll meet with him now I
consult you know I'm on my off times you
know on screenplays and whatnot I have a
consulting business but I don't but I I
only do it when I'm not working you know
cuz - its it's not you know the real
jobs are the assignment jobs so in the
down times I open it up and say you know
shops open you know yeah so I said I'll
do this as a freebie as a favor and a
lot of times you get you it stings you
and bites you and that you nowhere so I
went to meet with this guy at Starbucks
and he brings in a giant screenplay and
I go what is this Eagle it's a TV pilot
I get it okay
and he starts dropping names of people
who I know that are going to give him an
office in the thing and I was like
they're gonna give you an office what
about me yeah so I said okay I'll read
it so I went home and and there were 10
I'm not kidding you 10 issues on every
page from typos to format to whatever
you want and so we met again and I was
really doing my friend a favor we met
again and he had an excuse for everyone
and wouldn't listen and I he said well
I'm gonna chop it in half and make it
the thing okay interesting and still
went on and I'm dropping these names
about people I know are somehow gonna
bring him in and give him a desk in her
office and I was just like I can only do
so much you know good luck to you and
maybe I'm wrong I doubt it but okay
people who don't want to listen it
obviously shows their ignorance and it's
it's I'm not trying to be malicious I'm
just trying to say hey you know I wish
somebody had done that to me and you
know then it would save me a lot of time
and time is what keeps clicking away you
know when you make mistakes why spend
all this time making these mistakes when
you could do it right you know or go
down this path everyone has to learn
hopefully they do but yes I I've
experienced that where they people just
tune off and they're like huh
okay and is that around the time when
you say it's going to take several
scripts it's gonna take always have
multiple things so that if someone
that's why I went to talk at a high
school my friends a teacher - they're a
film class and one of the kids raises
hand goes you ready
have you written any big movies how long
do we have on this you know so we went
through the thing and you can just see
all the they're not gonna you know but
the few film nerds which I was one
growing up after it was over they came
up three or four great you know came up
and said oh and they wanted to look at a
script and talk to me direct everybody
else couldn't wait to leave and I just
thought huh interesting
I was making films when there was their
age you know doing that and they can do
whatever maybe they weren't interested
that's okay but I always say you'll be
humbled if you're not humble now the
craft and the business will humble you
eventually where you say oh my one
script and then you learn that you know
after 35 screenplays either you're still
learning what you should be and it takes
a lot to get one that's why the multiple
projects thing is important to have
multiple projects going at each time and
that's to say you have to write two
projects but always have something you
finish one you're working on another
don't leave these long gaps you know of
nothing and you're out there and my spec
that I sold it took seven years but I
didn't that wasn't my only thing I had I
wasn't running around town with this one
spec I continued on doing other things I
I was in a sketch comedy show I was
doing proactive things at the same time
but the only problem is that once is
sold I didn't have a specific spec like
in the same genre where they could say
what else can I look at or things
weren't ready you know it's important to
to have those those other things ready
because like I said if you have that
meeting and they say oh send over
something you don't want it to be six
months later you want it to be you know
immediate immediately you seem like a
very positive upbeat person
and I know everybody has good days and
bad I try yeah but when I'm on camera
I'm the back okay yeah well that's most
people that's most of us myself included
yeah but so but you said something about
in in the book the naysayers who whisper
their own fears into your ears and I
know I'm going down a negative path here
but that does exist with anything
creative that people do and I was just
wondering if we could just talk on that
a little bit yeah there's also sometimes
jealousy now when I when I got into film
school you know the odds are 1 out of 7
I went to UCLA film school and one of my
close friends who I grew up with did not
he applied to the same in the same time
and we were juniors we were trying you
know and so as a junior you if you
didn't get in you really couldn't amass
more credits you had to like chill out
for a year so he didn't get in and so
when I remember that fateful phone call
and I said I got the letter he said what
does it say I said congratulations I got
in I mean it was a most amazing day to
get into film school because you know
and he said oh maybe they got our
letters mixed up and I was like yeah
I'll talk to you later
with the phone as I vow okay how did you
know
jealousy yes there are naysayers who are
going to say oh why do you think you can
make it or but you know they're really
that's them projecting their
insecurities upon you like a like I said
earlier about the person who said what
if you don't make it by 30 well by 32 I
had produced an independent feature with
an Academy Award nominee that I co-wrote
and I also had worked on a popular game
show you know I was I had done a few
things so I said maybe I was two years
off the Mahr off from his you know mark
but yeah you have to watch because you
know we have our own internal voices of
fear and so if they're constantly you
know filling your head with that
nonsense and you say oh no and then
later in the middle of the night you go
well maybe what about what if you know
they're right it's tough because not
everybody's gonna support what you do
that's why like I said I was blessed to
have parents who said go for it you know
we know it's going to be hard but you
know life's not easy
why not enjoy what you do because most
people a lot of people don't enjoy their
day job I mean it's it's okay but
they're working for the weekend or
they're working for something else and I
always saw my father not enjoy his job
and I said I wanted I want to do
something that I want to get paid to do
and it may not make millions of dollars
but to wake up and sit down and write
and create for a living I still kind of
get a you know kick out of him like oh
my gosh I get you know I'm living my
childhood dream you know it's 11 year
old kid making films to be able to you
know see them my name on a larger small
screen and be on the set and see actors
say the lines or work you know do
rewrites on the set and you know
interact with other creative people then
you're you know it's just it was a dream
you know speaking of which I was
watching an interview with an author
that has sold millions of copies of
their book and they had a book signing
in a book reading and they invited their
family member a sister and the sister
showed up late and then the author said
well what do you think and the sister
said you know what I like that first guy
what was his name I want to get his book
and so you'd said something about
writing like no one cares or I'm
probably butchering a little bit but
right like no one really cares right
right for yourself because that is a
perfect example right there yeah and and
in the bigger picture nobody really
cares
I mean you care you have to care about
your screenplay but no one else you know
like I say my producers care what I
write because they're they're paying me
to write his assignment it's a
protective bubble but you know you have
to it has to start with you you have to
care about what you're writing you know
first and foremost and and that'll show
through if you're if you're inauthentic
where you're trying to just you know
cheat and write something for money or
write something that's you're trying to
follow a trend and copy something else
you know it'll show through and it won't
be like that's why I think my spec sold
because it was a heartfelt and you know
I think it poured it out on the page
you know because I I know I don't say
this in the book but I during the time
of starting the spec I had lost a family
member and so I stopped writing the
script and I came back it took me like
six or eight months to finally feel you
know not guilty about working on that
and I think a lot of that loss went into
the the characters you know what I mean
it was like and so many times your own
life experiences which I think should
reflect in your work and make it that
authentic you know what does an outline
look like well for me on these
assignments that I do they're usually
ten or twelve pages and it's the entire
story treatment and it's not just line
by line I mean there are somehow lines
it's just it's a line in line but for
these movies for television they're a
tax so everything has to be broken down
but I read it as a story so if you were
to sit down and read it you'd be reading
the story of the movie which I think is
essential to create because I find that
many in fact I've had friends that do
this so I'm just gonna sit down and I
have the vague idea and I'm just gonna
write and I'm like you'll you'll be lost
in the barren wasteland of act 2 with no
water you'll be in the desert you'll be
lost and you'll wonder how you're gonna
trudge through those 75 pages or
whatever I'm a huge advocate of outlines
before starting writing and I know it's
it's probably 50 60 70 percent of the
work you do because it makes the load a
lot easier and you can write a faster
screenplay if you have a good outline
now that doesn't say there's room
there's no room for changes or
improvising but if you don't have a
solid roadmap going in it's almost like
a pre draft of a first draft and I'm not
an advocate I know there's people say
that about the vomit draft or just spill
it out but I don't have the luxury of
spelling out on my assignment jobs I
don't I really have to turn in let's say
out of a ten scale I've got to turn in
probably an eight an eight you know how
to ten because
I'm now holding up development you know
and I've also done rewrites and other
screenwriters work projects that have
that were to page one rewrites which
means that the script that they have
went through multiple drafts and still
is not there and they have a buyer they
have a network who's waiting on the
script and so I've also been hired to do
rewrite job where I can come in but it's
like a page one rewrite where see the
script that you have you can't use any
of it the names yes the concept yes but
you basically and that's that's
something that I've learned how to do
which is good because there is a lot of
rewrite work out there and and some
writers look down on it upon oh you know
but but an example is that I took a
rewrite job and that ended up being
three more jobs with the same company
because that opened the door for them
and then they were thankful for that so
you never know what opportunity is is
gonna you know you're going to either
turn down or accept so but back to your
point about the outline I think is
extremely important to do an outline
before your screenplay because it's
easier to work out the problems there
than it is writing a complete first
draft and having just have so many
problems and also trained you like I
said it's a it's like you're an Olympic
athlete it trains you for the time when
you do have to do outlines because I'm
not allowed to write these assignments
without an outline that I have to create
so they won't just let me go to pages
they mean they have other people
involved to have to okay it so the
outline is extremely important in your
book do you have any examples of an
actual outline I know sometimes viewers
will ask where do I find a copy of an
outline because it's um I don't it's I'm
sure you can find it online but it's not
it's not that mysterious I mean there's
there's different there's a step outline
there's a there's a one sheet which is
the one one sheet of paper which is the
concept you know it's sort of a short
synopsis there's the logline which is
even smaller you know two or three
sentences so there's different steps and
and you have to have you have to have
each along the way
because you have the quick pitch I'm not
interested then you have the quick pitch
and they go hmm
I'm willing to read something not the
script but I'll read a synopsis then you
know there's different steps of how how
interested they are to read what you
want is the final product the final
script is for them to read but the the
treatment I mean there's many different
for you know again like a step outline
I've done outlines that were 30 pages I
mean completely just you triple it you
have the script but everything had to be
worked out because it was very technical
the way the film was gonna be shot was
from from like an iPhone and from
different things and so really had to be
spelled out you know there was no
because on the set you just can't leave
it up to chance so that's you know but
at that point I could have written the
script in weeks because it was all
figured out you know I figured it out
already and you want that outline for
those dark periods when you're stuck you
don't want to be stuck trying to figure
out plot points when you should be
filling pages that's the worst part
that's the worst place to be
how long does it usually take you to
write an outline let's let's see from
once the concept it's like two weeks and
I'm working every day and then that
usually ends up being 12 or 15 pages is
that as the outline in my in my
experience with my producers and that
outline is then rewritten sometimes two
or three times I mean I have to you know
I get notes on the outline before I'm
allowed to go to the script so the
script is like the final once we okay
the outline then go to pages and that's
not to say there they don't change their
mind once the scripts finished because
that's that's the crazy part because you
see yeah but you agreed to it the
outline but we built the house and now
we don't kind of like the way it looks
you know we thought we did
and so that happens too so you have to
be you know open and prepared for
rewrites at all stages but it does
allow you to write a faster first draft
is to have a solid outline because for
me I have to see the film in my head
before I can write it and I know that
I'm I have a lot of problems ahead of me
if I can't see it I mean I don't I don't
lock in like I've almost seen the movie
like you like when you watch a movie you
remember it I have to see it that way
and I know things are working when I
start to live and you know the outline
is good for living with your characters
you know you get to live with them you
get to you get to see how the movie is
working or doesn't work before you sit
down and write that screenplay which is
building the house you know that's
almost a Dupree blueprint and in my
opinion that's been my experience but I
know a lot of writers just want to write
down a couple of lines and and wing it
and there's so many so many things that
can go wrong and why why not turn in
your the most amazing first draft you
can I don't see the problem with that
and in fact like I say you have to when
you're doing assignment work you want
fewer drafts you don't want eight drafts
because nothing's working you know you
want to turn that where they go Wow
one of my assignments I did two drafts
and two polishes were done that's what
they like they don't like five you're
not getting it that's where you get
fired and they hire somebody else who
can facilitate the notes and get it
moving you know it's it's it's creative
but it's also a business at the same
time unfortunately mark when you meet
with the producer or you get an email or
a phone call and they're saying we want
to do this movie and they just give you
just a little bit less than a paragraph
of information what is that like for you
to create this outline and then go to
pages on that it's terrifying no no it
is because many times they have which I
like a definite idea because they have a
buyer or they have a network that's
already signed off which is called green
you know greenlit movie it's already
signed off on the concept they just need
to see a script that they can say oh I
see what you're doing and a few
sometimes it's two sentences it's a
pitch then I have to come back and and
and create an outline like we're talking
about maybe 10 12 pages of
story you know the treatment that's a
lot more work obviously than sometimes
when they give me a one sheet which is
one sheet of paper which is a synopsis
and usually the middle is kind of vague
and there is an ending point which you
okay this is how it wraps but even that
sometimes is vague there's there's beats
that are skipped and so um so that I
have to come up with the exact specific
detail way of how the movie ends not
like just in generalities like well you
know bah blah and then they end up in
jail and the other persons this you know
so which is okay because I'm living with
it I'm not just taking it and you know
what I mean it's it's it's now it
becomes that's why I saw an interview
and someone said well it's different
than spec writing assignment writing and
it is because it's not your baby but it
is your baby it becomes your baby it's
the adopted child you know that you love
because now it's your job and you better
love it because why are you doing the
job you know I mean okay you can do it
for money but if you're pounding away
going I hate this it's gonna show you
know and so you know everything shut
down and saying this is it becomes yours
even sometimes the the the rewrite jobs
become yours I think because you're
rewriting in your own style and voice
and fixing things and and you know they
how much is the old writers and how much
is yours and if it's 5050 who knows what
you know you could sit down and say in
that scene I did you know what I'm
watching it I can tell you exactly that
lines mine that's not and that's when
they came in and did that that's me
that's you know I mean that's going
through your head almost like a crazy
person watching about you know but so
that that's at least in my experience
that's how it's worked either it's a
it's a pitch that you know pitch me and
I'd a pitch me I've pitched them I've
also come to them with the one sheet but
you know many times that's like Oh
interesting but they they already know
what their buyers want I don't so it's a
lot easier for them to come
me and say we need this you're like okay
you know what I mean so but like you
said it takes up for me about two weeks
of solid work to get to treatment and
then that's rewritten before I'm allowed
to go to the screenplay so then if you
get the okay on the outline yes and
what's day one of pages like Dave one of
pages is and I'll just give you an
example because last Monday I turned in
a new assignment so day one of pages is
like starting a new job except it's at
my office you know it's the same
familiar surroundings but it's starting
a new job and luckily there wasn't a
great amount of time between me
finishing the treatment and and the
company saying go because I like it when
it's fresh still that I can jump right
on rather than this you know there's a
momentum that's really important about
things like that and so I sit down and
today is my first day of writing and I
look at my calendar and I know they have
30 days and so I do the math and I
divide up the days and I say okay I
should and I leave myself about a three
or four days at the end of you know I'm
not just gonna say fade out the end and
turn in the script I want to look it
over I want to fix things I want to
polish it but I don't want to be doing
that as I'm writing it because I can't
do that I have to push forward and
that's why a lot of times in the one I
just turned in I reread it from start to
finish and I was like oh but I didn't
revisit it for almost a month ago right
because I started and I was like it's
done that's not bad you know I start
having to feel that I didn't quite
remember if this was good or bad and
that there's some days and I think this
is good writing and there's other days
I'm like this is not good but I always
have my backup guide is my treatment
that I've worked on so there I'm not
just left hanging in the wind you know
but I did did get into a point and it
took a few days that I had about a five
or six page gap in the story where I was
gonna come up short you know and I have
a mandate about how many pages the
script has to be and I was like how did
I come up short and I find this too
sometimes when I
consult on people's treatments I said
you don't have enough story to
facilitate a hundred pages here you
think you do but you know then they put
into a half a page description and I can
break that down and say in an actual
page of script that's gonna be about a
half a page you know that's not me this
needs to be four or five pages of a
sequence you know what I mean so they
come up short many times so I worked
through that but like I said I had my
treatment to to fall back on and I knew
these characters so if I just let the
characters run you know they're gonna
you know you're there I'm gonna follow
them they're not gonna follow me I'm
just gonna you know ii mean i think you
know when when you know your characters
you follow them and let them run off and
say wait and say i got it you know and
so that was that was the first day and i
so i was a about three pages a day which
is a luxury but i've also worked on
scripts or headed to eight to ten pages
a day and i mean if you miss a day and
you can't miss a day and there's you
know there's things in life that
happened and a lot of stuff goes on but
but it's a day job i mean it's a day or
a night job and I'm lucky that I can
push my schedule where my day can start
at three o'clock and go till late you
know I mean I can shift it which is good
and that a few years ago I was working
on an assignment and that really messed
me up because I was I was worried more
about how he's starting my day so late
and I said why don't you just relax and
and and accept the fact that your day
starts at two o'clock and I did and you
know what it was great once I let go of
that I was productive for the next you
know eight hours so you know shifting
that the time helps but again I have I
don't see the luxury but that is my job
to do that to work all day on the script
and so I better be doing that you know
sure you trust yourself more now maybe
because in the beginning maybe it's
scary because you're like because you
don't know without the experience of
writing multiple screenplays and being
you know muddied in the trenches and do
you know fail you don't know you your
abilities and so you know I'm not overly
confident but I know what I can do
I say okay and then I met the deadline
for this last job and I had three or
four days left over and so that was a
luxury to be just now I can and it felt
great the night before it was due I
turned in you know emailed the script
and so that morning that producer would
get up and sure enough you know here it
is just like I said you know and and and
you always have to be building your
integrity constantly and they don't they
don't want to have to worry about you
the one that's that shooting now film
that I have shooting in Los Angeles the
producer is doing other movies at the
same time and he didn't want to have to
worry about me you know check up all if
I'm doing the job and all you know and
that's a good place to be because you
don't have to worry about me you know I
you know and so you only you only do
that by it by you know your experiences
when you turn in one job and work with
somebody they go okay you turn another
do it now that's just the norm your
integrity is built there you know which
is which is also vital for any
screenwriting career is your
professionalism and your integrity so in
the beginning when you would start let's
say a new script once you receive the
outline would you do like 8:00 a.m. and
the coffee's there and you're okay this
is it the clock's ticking or I mean how
were you able to finally say you know
what I'm better at two o'clock I know
myself I know how I need to have lunch
first I need to do all these different
pages clear my mind breaks but also the
day gets away you know and that's not
good either and so I'm I don't have to
you know eight o'clock being okay I got
to go you know but you know ease into
the morning and then start work and you
know I mean three pages a day is a
luxury but you know eight or ten that
were those are rough days you know and
some days you're not as productive and
you don't meet that deadline and but
other days you you explode into twelve
pages you know how did that happen so it
kind of evens out but but if you're
doing fewer pages a day you know you
know you only have so much time that's
why I say when writers are doing their
spec set your own self-imposed deadline
don't let it be open-ended where you
know oh yeah I was working on
this last year and Christmas came but
you know because you're gonna need that
training you know and even while you're
working in it with experience it's still
difficult you got to stand because
you're your own boss no one's no one's
calling me saying are you working today
and the day goes on and then you know
you mean you got to really stay on it
and realize there's a lot of self work I
mean it's like you're your own boss and
it's good in one way people say oh I
would love to do that but with that
comes a lot of responsibility you know
in keeping to that at that point and
with that are you ever saying to
yourself okay now it's time to turn off
because there is a fear that runs in
with being your own boss where yeah what
if I don't end in so but are there four
points where you say you know what I
need to stop now
yes I usually when I feel that it was
Bennett it's been a good day of writing
there'll be a point I forgot which
writer said this the famous writer that
you know leave something leave something
more tomorrow to come back to you know
and I always look at my characters like
they're waiting going okay you know we
were just at us at the end of the cliff
what are we uh we gotta wait till
tomorrow
you know don't have him jump the cliff
and then go to bed you know so when I
would finish a day's work it would feel
good to clock out so to speak at six
o'clock where I go I'm done you know but
I also knew that if I was behind it in
trouble I have the rest of the night you
know whatever needs to be done and but I
would prefer not to do that and also
weekends to a lot of people so you know
screenwriters don't always get weekends
off and so my friends who have day jobs
I go you work Monday through Friday I
work you know sometimes my weekends are
you know Monday and Tuesday you know
Saturday I have to hit the bricks you
know and and and do the work and that's
okay but they're like you you know you
know it's just what happens and it's
fine but but they behave the ability to
shift the schedule is is one of the
things that I enjoy and also the ability
to write anywhere in the world last year
I was in Italy for six weeks and I wrote
I wrote a job that I got in Los Angeles
so
producer didn't care where I was we
communicated but that was part of the
initial attraction of being a writer was
that you didn't need a big crew and you
didn't need all these you know spend two
years on a project that you could be in
a cafe somewhere you know in an Italian
island writing a movie nice so that that
but you also bottom line is you have to
write and stick to a schedule I mean
that's just that's vital that would be
very distracting it is I thought it
would be I thought it would be you know
I'm inside I'm like oh but there's all
this stuff outside that I should do
Vatican I want to see the Vatican yeah
but you get over that when you're like
okay I have to work you know that helped
me to go there so you know that's true
yeah for six weeks so Who am I to
complain sure sure yeah what are your
five worst screenwriting habits
five worst well it's writing while I'm
rewriting which is running like on a
treadmill you know you can rewrite after
you're done
but don't rewrite you know one time I
had a job and the contract stated they
wanted to see every ten pages and I was
like that's a deal-breaker for me and so
I told my attorney I said I don't want
that as your hire me to write the script
let me write the script that's what it
rewrites about you don't you won't know
in 10 pages you know to me it's like
running on treadmills you know that's
for me a habit that I don't do it's it's
tempting because when you get bored you
scroll back and you're like oh I wonder
what those you know and then you realize
the days go on you're like I should be
on page 50 and I'm on three because I
really you know worked on those three
that's what I rewrite times for another
bad habits let me see
well fear I don't know if that's a habit
but that's a you know there's a lot of
fear involved in writing you're sitting
with the blank page that you have to
fill and like I've said before you can
alleviate that by having a solid
treatment which is sort of your buddy
you know and your roadmap and you won't
sit there and just waste time
procrastination
is another terrible one and I'm guilty
of it as well a bad habit there's always
something to distract you and then like
I say when the writing gets difficult
which it does it's the easiest time to
run away from it and I found that even
when you sit with it like I think
Raymond Chandler said he sat at his desk
every day at the same time if he if
anything happened or it didn't you know
it's that constant repetition which
writing is it's not oh I'm you know
waiting for my muse you know so I still
have to I mean the last job was
procrastinating but I had three pages a
day which was a light schedule but I
found myself on the internet and looking
up stuff and you know procrastination is
horrible what are we at now three are
your three and three number four
can I come up with two other ones bad
habits
let me thank you mean personal habits
screenwriting
yeah screenwriting habits over writing
something I don't do but I warn against
it because when I consult on scripts I
read that there's just you know
describing the wallpaper and you know
you have to know what you need to put in
what you need to leave out and I find a
lot of beginning writers you know hang
on so desperately that they're not gonna
understand it or then what can't my you
know you know you don't describe the
chandelier unless the diamonds are part
of the heist you know I mean you start
to read people's clothing and all these
and it adds up and so that's when you
end up with 120 page scripts and why hmm
and you look through and go cut this out
it's you know they don't want to see all
this description and all this stuff and
that's a technique it's to know when to
stay out of the way which is important I
think for writers like you've got to
know when when to put your imprint on it
but stay out of the way you know and so
what are we up to for now before but if
yes and five what's the other one I
don't know I can't come within the fifth
that's okay yeah
so when you catch yourself
procrastinating do you sometimes just
say alright I'm just gonna do it for a
little bit get it out of my system or
what do you do to be your own well again
we're not working alone I used two years
ago have a writing partner you know so
that helps to have somebody go hey or
you're together because it's both of
your your collective time you're not
wasting somebody else's time when you're
alone you can waste as much time as you
want right it's just my time but I
usually realize that I'm doing it and
then snap back into like oh I should be
it's it's tough you know distractions
that's why you have to go somewhere
right if you have an office or they have
office spaces now that you could rent
yeah and it's a short-term thing per day
and one time a producer hired me an
assignment and he paid for that office
space so I could go there and it was it
was something about like when I go to
the gym you made a commitment to take
that trip to get there and park and so
you're gonna be productive rather than
working at home when there's a lot of
distractions if you have a family
somebody knocking door phone ringing
other times I've worked at a library you
know and when it's quiet and things like
that so your work environment is also
very important to fight off the forces
of procrastination yeah the whole
co-working culture is very interesting
yeah what about over writing I was
wondering if you could maybe just give
me an example of something that's
overwritten versus shortening it down
well mainly it's in descriptions in the
script but also over writing the
dialogue you know where you could go
through and in a piece you could say you
don't need that beginning sentence you
know you're saying the same thing in
repetition two lines from now you know
really getting concise down to the point
of having or overriding where characters
say something and you could say it would
be better if they just had a reaction
you know I always try to err on the side
of let it let the actors act and emote
rather than say something you know if
you see someone's eyes 60 feet on the
screen that's going to say a lot more
than a line of dialogue you know
so you cut cut cut cut cut cut they say
cut the dialogue and then cut it 20%
more than that you're like oh lean and
no-one wants to because but I've read
screenplays that read like a stage play
and you're like that's not that's not
what this is or scenes every director
I've worked with so give me something to
shoot where the scene is just flattens
and two people sitting that Quentin
Tarantino can do it with the interesting
dialogue with ten pages of dialogue but
two characters sitting in the dinner
scene you know the directors I worked
with is they hate it they're lazy what
are we doing it's just this this this
you know and plus the food will be
spoiled you know it's it takes a long
time to film it you know so yeah the in
overwriting the descriptions like I said
before about describing things there
that are not your job you know you just
set the scene if it's a castle you don't
have to say and all the intricacies of
the interior of the castle and then the
corner there's a knight in shining armor
and there's a thing in the tapestry the
set designer will will do that you know
you have to you have to stand back and
in in a way you have to really know what
what you need to put in it's necessary
and what is unnecessary and I think a
lot of beginning writers don't know that
that fine line and they just put
everything in it you know and so if
someone were to read it and it drags
would they know let's suppose it's their
work and they think oh no but I'm
describing this interaction between two
people and the tension and it's great
but then an outside person is looking at
it saying this is dragging yeah cut to
the chase what's going on you know less
is always more is you know what I mean
and I've always found that and you find
producer I worked with he caught the
repetition and dialogue and I didn't
even see it and he said you're saying
the same thing here again we don't need
it I'm like oh my god you're right and
he's a big
anti repetition you know producer and I
never had that before a producer like
would point out those specifics like oh
you're right I've got this bad habit now
of not even seeing it and so now I'm
very cognizant of that when I work with
him and in general that you know we only
have so much time on this
Green and so many pages and and if you
don't like the constraints then write a
novel we can do whatever you want but if
you like the screenplay format you know
you have to have these dense packed
scenes with subtext but not go on for
six eight pages you know there's a
rhythm to it you have a feel like you
say when you start reading that the
scripts overwritten and you just know
everything's described in the writers so
afraid to let go that their their vision
or their ideas won't come through on the
page well once they take that script and
make it yeah but you want to you know
your imprint is the script so you know
all these other little particulars are
not going to help when it's overwritten
for your new book you touch on how you
know talent is important but
professionalism and the ability to
endure criticism rejection and failure
over the long haul is imperative so I'm
wondering if you know of any colleagues
or any situations where the talent was
absolute like rock solid there was no
doubt that this person was incredibly
talented but they couldn't handle any
little bit of rejection and it cost them
no known people who have a lot of talent
and they're working but not one in that
situation among my peers that I know
know okay
what about ability to handle criticism
everybody I know is pretty much I mean
it's just the way you have to to be if
you're gonna be a screenwriter or writer
in general is to have you know now it's
constructive criticism is the most
important thing and and we receive
criticism oh I would have done it
differently or something it's okay
that's fine but it's hard rejection
criticism if you put yourself out there
you're going to be criticized and many
people don't finish things I find
because if they never finish it they'll
never know that it sucks and they'll
never be criticized because they're
still working on it you know it's a work
in progress for a number of years or
like didn't you finish that I'm still
working on it that's a safe place to be
then putting it out there and getting
smacked around and that's only that's
that's how you learn and that's the only
way you're gonna learn and then after
you're in it for a while you learn to
filter those notes like notes from
producers or assistants you learn to
filter the good notes from the bad or
even notes that are vague and then you
kind of are left to go off and figure
them out but if you ask too many
questions in me like well don't you
understand what I want oh I do and then
you leave you're like I don't know I
want to ask you know what about someone
who sabotages themselves and I probably
asked this question before but I think
Julia Cameron said that
a failed writer is going to get a lot
more empathy and supporters around them
than someone that's actually successful
and then you're driving people away
because they're looking at their own
career or whatever it is a failed writer
has more people hmm kind of cheering
them on and patted them you're gonna do
it and he's going through yeah and if
you have any success or like well you
you know like you didn't work for it or
you didn't sacrifice for it yeah
whatever I mean yeah I suppose so
not everybody I went to film school is
working today and some were working in
different capacities but not you know
like writing like what we all were like
yeah and that's fine some are very
successful and you know always everyone
is not all going to be at the same level
but yeah yeah it's just sabotage in
general of themselves avatars yeah where
they just yeah I had a friend in film
school he would he would self-sabotage
because he never wanted to he was a rule
breaker I'm gonna break all the rules so
he write these scripts that were like
double the size of a script and the
wrong cover you know all these things
right up front and they would just put
him in the trash and he is extremely
knowledgeable about film I mean like
crazy but it didn't translate into the
realities of the business and so he's
like oh I said well you can break the
rules once you know them and you're in
but you're trying to be this maverick
and nobody cares you know
and he really hard head you know just
wouldn't listen and that I think was
self sabotaging you know it you know I
mean it still I don't know to this day
if you listen to this place I'm not sure
well I think there's this like romantic
idea especially in rebellious types of
beingness like Hunter s Thompson or this
you know Janis Joplin of yeah I'm just
gonna let it all out and you know and
but then if you maybe go and look at if
you pull back the curtain on those two
the ultimate sort of rebels yeah there
was a method to what they were doing
yeah I just wasn't
the dice and hoping for the best you
know there's always I have to believe
there's always a method behind a plan if
you don't you're you're lost I mean it's
it's a very difficult business to
achieve any success and if you go in it
just blind with no and stumble around
it's not here maybe it works for some
people I don't know I never found it to
be the case what does a good writing day
look like good writing D looks like I
get up and I've had a successful
previous day writing and I've left it
the script at a point where I feel that
I've done my work yesterday
so I'm not feeling guilty or bad or like
or under pressure and I can just start
up again and you know get my work done
in the morning I mean you know emails
and all these other things and just work
and then take lunch and then come back
and you know maybe five six o'clock wrap
it up now that depends on how many pages
a day I have to do and as I say many
days are good solid days and other days
are not so good and not every scene is
going to be you know on the level and
then there's other days where it's
magical where you you blow through a
sequence and you you write two days in
one day so you're ahead of the game so
it varies while you're in it but but it
is kind of gonna say scary but once that
you know the starting gun goes and you
look at the I always look at the
calendar because of my due date and I've
agreed and then like on the last
assignment
we had interaction for some other reason
about another project with them and I
said oh by the way I'm on target to turn
it in on Monday and they say oh thanks
you know and they didn't bug me the
whole time they're not sniffing around
saying hey are you you know because they
know I'm not trying to you know pat
myself on the back but they know because
I've worked with them before and they
know that they don't have to be sending
that like how's it going you know email
at being a Nancy they just leave me
alone which is great place to be right
you know so a good writing day is like I
said having a good now again the day was
crappy before
you know you get up and you you you do
it again you know what I mean just it's
a day after day and it's amazing what
you can accomplish in a month I mean you
know you when people think oh this big
ordeal about writing a script you know
it's gonna take me six months it may be
but if you structure your time properly
and I do have the time because my job
you structure your time properly two
pages a day you know I mean you'll have
something finished and and that's it's
just doing it and most people don't do
it you know that's the thing why do you
think they don't do it I don't know it's
I mean a lot of its fear maybe a lot of
its I'll get to it tomorrow and there's
always something else to do and it's
difficult and so if you're writing
something you don't really care about
you know why you're gonna go back to it
and just be like ah and if you're not
getting paid that's another I don't say
great incentive but when you're getting
paid and you sign a contract that's that
kicks your butt you know into high gear
rather than just but you have to that's
what I'm saying when you write in your
specs you have to treat it as as that
it's lights like a second day job it is
if you just and I'm not saying you have
to do ten pages a day but if you do two
pages today and like when I was working
at the law firm for two years at lunch I
would write I would write by hand but I
wanted to like not just sit there and be
like uh you know I was so every day at
lunch that was an hour that's five hours
a week including the time at night you
know it's doable if you just plant it to
plant it out you know so you're looking
at the due date then you're looking at
how many pages and then you're putting
sort of a red X on a calendar and you're
basically doing how many pages a day
well it depends on what I'm given you
know but this last job I worked on was
three pages a day which was was your
luxury that's not normal right this room
I mean three to five oh three five
yeah the really the really hard scripts
are eight to ten when it's a short
period like a rewrite or it's like we
need this in two weeks
whoa you know you hang up the phone
you're like huh
okay you know in like this year I've
you're always learning I'd be glad to
become a faster writer not that I'm a
slow writer but I would take my time you
know but not as fast as and I knew if I
was going to be taking more jobs I would
have to be a faster writer and what
would I just do that on my own I was
forced to do that by challenging myself
you know which I think is very important
to always challenge yourself and many
times we don't challenge ourself unless
we come up against something which
challenges us and so that was a
particulars I did the job and then I was
like oh wow okay and I knew I could do
it but at first I didn't think I could
do it and so I went back to my old
techniques and it's funny sometimes I
forget them and someone says to me you
know you should buy this book and you
really go yeah and they start talking
about it I go oh you mean my book and
they go yeah you've forgotten your
disciplines I know you're right you know
I mean it's like oh yeah you're right
you got it you know it's funny but yeah
that's incidentally just to throw this
in there your book is now at the Santa
Monica library which is where you know
yes high school I used to work there as
a page which is shelving books it was a
nice clean job you know and so now it's
four how ironic that years later and my
book is at the library that I used to
work at you know and I had to go in the
other day of four copies it's pretty
cool yeah that's pretty cool and it's
right next to you know there's John
McKee and and Truby and and you know
screenwriting for dummies and then
there's my book I'm like wow dude double
take and it's been checked out you know
which since they've got it it's been out
you know people checking it out so it's
good and you came across that by
accident I went in there and then yeah
it was they have some of my DVDs of
movies that I've written you know and
you know they order things however and
so it was cool because it's nice that
people can access it and then maybe you
know it's a kind of book
that is not just a read in one time it's
you can go back to it many times I think
that's how I wrote it where you can you
know pick it off the shelf and look at
the particular things I'm going through
this problem you know and maybe it would
help you with that type of thing that's
how I wanted to write it was the fact
that you could it's something you would
keep you know next to your computer and
you could go you know some books you
read once and that's it but you know
it's uh it's about all these things I've
been talking about but surviving you
know in the trenches as a writer or
living a writer's life let's imagine
you're on this script assignment and you
turn in exactly what they've asked for
yes and then you receive notes back that
the story is too thin and the female
lead is underwritten what would you do
hmm well that would be I would I would
be in trouble because hopefully I would
have done that in the treatment you know
I would have figured that out but
obviously something is wrong right I
would have to go back and look at the
scenes and see why the character was not
strong or was not driving the action and
perhaps you know obviously that would be
from early on in the script you know to
nail that finding and then see that
through line of them pushing like I did
a consulting job on a treatment and they
were giving all this stuff the good
stuff to the supporting characters you
know and you're like that stuff needs to
happen to the protagonist do they need
to be pushing it you know you give it
all you know to the you know they were
there but they had the wrong person
doing the wrong things to drive the
story because it's this person's story
you know luckily that again that I don't
hope that wouldn't have slipped through
the cracks hopefully because of the
treatment that's that's my example when
I was talking about how important those
treatments are that could happen if you
didn't structure the script properly and
you know didn't know they had to beef up
the protagonists part
and just be like oh yeah along the way
I'm losing my my way you know well let's
let's change it then a little bit and
let's suppose you received a script that
you're gonna do a rewrite on yes and
those were the notes that they that the
producers gave you that okay the problem
with this script is that the story is
too thin and the female lead is
underwritten now how would you sort of
work away around it and I realized we
don't have a lot of other details but I
would go back to what the movies about
you know and I almost would not be I
didn't want to be too influenced by that
draft you know I'd have to read it
obviously and like when I do a page one
rewrite they're like you see everything
here yeah this is not matching what we
need and so I have to start from scratch
almost you know and so then I can beef
up that character and find the flaws
that are missing there and hopefully
take their note and and because I can be
so objective which is hard when you
write it is that I can read it to and
say oh yeah
I see where this is lacking let's get to
work on it you know I think it's a
little more difficult when it's your
work that's why sometimes when these
rewrites jobs I do it's it's very easy I
say easy but it's easier to be objective
because I have no this is I'm coming
fresh and I don't go remember that one
scene was my favorite you know no this
is this is what needs to be done to fix
it another a hypothetical situation
let's imagine you were hired to write a
script and it was agreed upon that it
would be a hundred pages you turned in
the hundred page script on time then
they come back to you and said you know
what the budgets gone down and now the
script needs to be 80 pages how would
you start going back through and taking
away 20 pages well in all honesty I
don't see an 80 page script being a
feature okay we could change the number
I'm saying one more money is is let's
suppose it's oh yeah 120 120 and then
they say you know what let's cut those
20 pages let's make it a hundred
yes what I would do to to make it
cheaper movie or I mean it yeah and yeah
what are you taking out and how are you
what you're taking out is is things like
locations are expensive the number of
characters usually the you know the
character that doesn't really do
anything do you really need it and it's
a good way to approach your writing
because a lot of times you know if you
write a script that has a lower budget
you know I think it's an easier way you
know if it's a $500,000 budget you know
that might get made a lot easier than
you coming in with the script it's a
hundred million dollar budget you know
and they say who are you again and
what's who's attached you know you can
actually go and raise the money yourself
like much like we did with our
independent feature that we did you know
is a certain budget range and we did it
you know
but those things with a budget always
rely upon locations night shooting you
know animals you know animals need a
Wrangler children can only work a
certain amount of time they need a
teacher if it's you know on the set so
these kind of things are all have to be
thought about but you know it can you
double up on locations where they can
film here in this living room is one
location and the backyard is a
completely separate house you know I
mean things like this so but you have to
have worked in that kind of world to to
know that about how I can go in and cut
this down you know what I mean rather
than just write your spec and say you
know ten thousand soldiers jump out you
know climb over the ravine you know it's
like okay how are we gonna do that you
know CGI but you know things like that
you know and that's an ability to know
about it how to how do and if you don't
have that ability where they hand you
the script back and say could you pare
this down and turn in something that's
they will fire you and they'll find
somebody who can do it I mean it's just
the nature of the business
what about advice to writers have been
fired off a project well you know
there's there's a firing and then
they're sort of like we're going to go
with someone else you know which is a
firing it's not quite as like you're
fired it's always thank you very much
and now we're going to have this other
writer finish it
and then you share credit you know what
I would say to them is learn from what
happened on that with that particular
producer and not make those mistakes
again or maybe they're not as good of a
writer as they thought they were so they
were able to get in with the script but
they weren't able to stay on it which i
think is important to stay through the
end luckily i'm most of my projects i've
stayed through the end and sometimes
even been on the set doing rewrites
because the director wanted me there i
had that relationship with with the key
you know members but you want to stay
through the whole thing you don't want
to be the person that leaves if you're
leaving because you have another job and
you can't do it that's different but if
you're leaving because they don't want
you anymore then that you probably won't
work with that producer again what if
it's a combination of that and politics
and you know that let's suppose there's
a little bird in your ear letting you
know that you know they brought someone
else on and that person's worked with
that other person before throw it and
you know that and you just have to kind
of swallow your pride in us well that
happened to me when I was working on the
game show you know I was told this is
earlier one of my first professional
jobs I was told that I didn't have
enough experience to do a certain during
production experience and I went through
the development of six weeks of writing
the show and then they shoot the show
but during that point I was let go and
they said we're bringing in somebody it
was someone who had a connection in the
writers room and I thought well I went
through the whole writing I don't
understand but it was just strange how
yeah you know and I was let go and I was
like okay I understand but it was it was
hard to be let go you know because I had
taken that job and I had quit my
restaurant career so called as a waiter
and that was my first professional job
and then to lose it that's why in the
book I said how I was fired from my
first professional job at Christmas
right at Christmastime you know but it
happens and then you you're not
guaranteed anything you know the hardest
thing that I had to learn when I fir
started getting paid to write was that I
thought everything I wrote would get
made of course it would be well I have
probably five projects sitting on a
shelf their production ready I was paid
for all the drafts and nothing myriad of
reasons because the marketplace changes
economics their buyers decided to go
with a different genre the actor bowed
out and they want you know financing
felt through all things that were not my
problem you know I'm just the writer
right but that was the hardest thing but
I mean it's not hard anymore I realized
the realities of the business did not
you know and but that was the hardest
thing I thought everything I wrote would
be made I never thought that when I
wrote my specs of course obviously to
every spec your rights gonna sell right
but to be let go of a job you you have
to learn and why it's a learning
experience you don't want too many you
know what you know that to happen too
many times because then the word will
get around and you won't work but no no
your producers and what they want you
know and so luckily the producers I work
with I know kind of now after working
for so long what they want and that's
what they want they won't have to leave
you alone everywhere is he gonna turn in
the thing and you know cuz we got people
waiting and a lot of money you know they
don't want to have to worry about that
but you have to build into that you know
so a writer that gets in somehow luck
maybe whatever sells the script but
doesn't have that ability to see it
through to the end that's a terrible
thing because you think oh I've sold it
now yeah and you're not staying on it
because you can't do the rewrites you
know I'm sorry but we need to take this
into production and we need to get
through development and if you can't do
it we will find someone who can how was
Christmas that year uh it was okay not
great because I was without a job you
know well not only that sorry to
interrupt but you know you were leaving
one world oh yeah to go to this world
that she'd been waiting for yes
and it's Christmas I got through
Christmas and how was New Year's it was
fine because a few months later my spec
was optioned oh okay so I was you know I
from the ashes like a phoenix you know
so I was like didn't have to go back to
the restaurant and vowed and I never did
so that that you know that's my point
about having multiple projects or things
if I had nothing else that I would be
out knocking on doors gonna huh you know
but that if you charted the course
before that first job that spec was was
constantly trying to find its way and
finally ended up with with the proper
timing the right home with the company
said we want to make this so yeah we
talked about your process for rewriting
let's talk about rewriting your own
project or a project that you're
initially hired to write not someone
else's first yeah so what's your process
on that you open up your computer you
sit down you're not really looking at
prior pages before that time I'm
assuming rewriting as you mean I've
turned in a draft and they give me notes
yeah yeah and they say okay we like this
but here's some notes and then you're
going back over from pretty much page
one sure
last month we just went through that and
we'll probably go that through again
next month because I just turned in
something but last month the movie
that's shooting now I did rewrites the
first draft was pretty solid the second
draft a few sequences changed because of
particular things and so there's always
a list of notes specific of what needs
to be changed and what's not quite
working and needs to be finessed and
many things are sometimes technical
without getting in particulars but how a
sequence is done is you know it's always
objects well how would that person get
that thing you know and in my mind I
write it but then there's the director's
mind who has to really shoot the film
and so that doesn't come into play till
the director comes on board and so then
the notes come in from the producer and
then maybe let's say another producer
who hasn't chimed in yet and then the
director and then they say okay and the
directors looking at it hopefully about
how can I shoot this film with the money
that I have and your mind but I've never
been at the locations so then a lot of
the notes changed where we can only get
this kind of place
need a tweet for that and you go okay
and those are you know those are great
you know or don't have them have this
thing have them do you know I'm being
vague but you know objects guns whatever
you know things in the script so you go
through with almost a checklist and you
go and make the fixes and hopefully like
I said with a solid treatment it
shouldn't be like the house of cards
you know implodes because that's not the
place to be in development when you're
like oh my gosh I've got to rewrite like
this whole thing you know it's still
solid a B and C still happens but you
get in you start to you know and then
and there's there is a sequence that
changed by its own nature and I agree
with totally with the changes because
it's much you'll see a lot of nobody
sets out to make a bad movie and the
changes are not personal they're like oh
we thought of it and it's terrible
somebody had to think of it somebody had
to write it down somebody had to create
it and then comes the realities of
shooting a movie and so you know my job
at that point is to help them make the
movie my job is to help the producing
director's job make the film I'm not
standing in their way whatever needs to
be changed it's changed because now
we're now we're moving through
development to a reality face not this
fantasy of like oh these you know
motivations have to track if they don't
they say this is kind of weird with that
character do this maybe the other would
flip or you were saying about the strong
you know keeping in mind the protagonist
well you gave that to this other
character she should be doing this
you're like oh yeah you're right and
it's just an easy fix because the
character then now is driving the story
and it's happening to them rather not
pushing it off to co-star or something
you know and it's very obviously
methodical but it is kind of methodical
because you know after doing this for so
long that it's like this is what needs
to be done and double checking me going
back through looking at all that you
know putting on revision mode so they
can you know see with the you know so
everybody's on the same page and then
they get it and and the nicest thing is
to hear even you know do a quick polish
let's say a couple date
polish which is you know fixing little
things is that the producer or director
comes back and says that was great job
you know still I still get happy you
know I'm still happy about hearing that
somebody says because they don't have to
say good job you know your job is you
know you got paid but great job and on
time because if you had taken a week
that would push you know I mean they're
already scouting locations they're doing
things I don't want to hold up that I
want to get this turned around as fast
as I can also to get off my plate to
open up for other work you understand so
you want to be the team player as I say
an ultimate collaborator at all steps in
the way and know your and know your
place in the bigger picture and so when
I go to the set if I'm not working on
the set I'm a guest you know I'm there
it's nice I've been on sets that I've
worked writing and you know have also
been on sets as a guest where the
director returned to me and he knew like
my first spec how long it took to get it
made and he would turn to me and say
what did you think of that take and I'm
like you talking to me can I go actually
I thought it was actually goes me to
moving on you're like you know angels
are in the back yeah I mean that that's
the great that's the great stuff you
work for and then there's the the dark
you know stormy nights when you're in
despair and all these other things but
you really work you know or that movie
premiered at the Palm Springs Film
Festival it opened
oh and so we had a theater of 300 people
and I'm sitting with the stars and and
one of them I grew up as a kid watching
his academy or nominee and I'm like and
he turns over after the movie and he
grabs my arm II says great job mark and
I'm like was she talking to him oh yeah
I wrote this movie and then we get up
and we do the Q&A and someone asks the
the star the lead they said you know in
that one scene I love what you said your
son was so amazing and you know an actor
could have went thank you very much you
know and and the star of the movie said
well you know people always say this to
actors what they say is genius he said
but without the writer and he put his
arm around me and he pulled me close he
said there would be nothing to say
and there was another leg huh you know
so you have these these these high of
highs but it's not always that sure but
but it that that sounds like it's worth
the except you sell the others yeah the
hard work and stuff and you want to get
to that point where you're on the set
and you're an equal collaborator not
just a fanboy going oh my gosh oh yeah I
wrote this you're right you know and
then even more when I've had
relationships with the director who said
I want you on the set just as a good
luck piece because we start making
changes I want somebody to go hello you
know a lot going on in the set and
people forget and things fall through
the cracks well the writer is gonna be
go hey hey you know that line you might
not want to cut it you know because it's
gonna change things
so that's but also you don't want to be
they don't want writers on the set
because they are changing things and you
want to be the uh you know grumbling and
say you know walking around angry you're
like how could you be angry you're
eating seared ahi at the craft service
and you're beat got paid and these
wonderful actors are elevating your
material I mean you know sounds good to
me sounds nice to me yeah
what if you what's day one of a rewrite
like for someone else's work so they've
given you notes this is what the person
gave us the other writer gave yeah this
is what's wrong it's the same you're
saying it is different than my own I
guess then it is is this the same
process then yeah it's just it's it's
chipping away you know my own rewrites
is based upon notes of people that I
trust like like saying a spec I would
give it to my circle of writer friends
who would give me notes I'd say mmm yeah
and then okay and then go about the
rewrite but it's it's similar to when
you know just check off the checklist
and say okay and and get that draft done
and and push that push push each draft
closer to the the final realization of a
production draft we know which is I mean
obviously your spec is a spec it's not a
production but I mean in a rewrite my
job is to push that as quick as I can to
get these changes made and not hold up
everything and you're doing these
changes in in numeric order and
the script page yeah I mean they're
specific which I love other times I've
had broad strokes like well you know
which I've put in the book some of the
notes the the emotional highs have to be
higher and the lowers have to be lower
what what does that mean
and then they go okay good luck see in a
week and you're like I don't know what
you're talking about
wait you know yeah and then if you come
back and ask too many questions they're
like why don't we hire you again you
know you don't know what you're doing
yes I do you don't know what you're
doing you know not all producers know
how to talk to writers properly if they
think they do
sure and the really good ones do where
they like really get in there because
some of them are writers as well but the
ones that just paint a broad stroke and
then say see you later and they're busy
with their other projects and you're you
have to learn how to filter that and go
with the emotional highs and lows what
what page what character I don't
understand anything you don't understand
okay and they pull the chute and you're
walk you're gone you know this is
leaving Las Vegas low yeah yeah re
Poppins high yeah exactly it's like what
are we what are we doing so but the one
that page specific notes are which then
become scene specific notes once there's
the scene numbers you know happen there
like in this scene XY and Z and you're
go okay ba and this dialogue here blah
you know and so you just go in and do it
change change and change you know and
turn that draft in and hope that's
closer and closer and closer what you
don't want is to be farther and farther
away that's when you bring somebody else
in isn't asking questions good or does
that show a weakness you mean ever
producer it does but there's only so
much time you're gonna have in the
office and then they almost want you to
be like you know in there in if there
isn't a shorthand between you and the
producer like we've worked together for
five years
you don't know what they mean and so if
you start going ahead I don't understand
then it's never gonna be upon them to go
well I'm not communicating properly it's
gonna be you don't understand yeah I
understand one time is in a meeting with
the producer and I had never worked with
him before and I was working on
assignment and he said something off the
cuff which is kind of insulting like
could you explain it to him it's like
screenwriting 101 and I looked I was
like and almost I went over my head and
they thought oh my gosh he just insulted
me and I let it go but I was like who
are you talking I you know I get it but
you don't get I don't know how you work
you're all over the place I'm trying to
grasp a thing which changes to another
thing and I'm like ah but you can't be
right you can't say that you know you
can it's a fine line you got to know how
to how to you know apply yourself when
you need to and and not just like like
with fighting your battles with notes
you know the situation I worked with a
producer who then handed me off to the
executive producers who I never worked
with and he went off to do something
else and now I was with them and I was
the defender of our screenplay the last
line of defense right and so they were
talking by Skype and this and that and
they say well we want to change this
thing at the end I was like oh no no no
no I said because I said we really work
so I'd if I I decided to make that my
battle it wasn't a battle but you know I
mean to talk back and discuss it and I
really hit home because I knew if they
started pulling these Lynch pins out it
was just gonna be like are you and they
had their own reason in which I guess
and so I defended it and then there was
this big silence and the producer is
quiet and he's like ok moving on I was
like I won that battle I wasn't gonna
win two battles you know now if he has
another thing that I have a problem with
and be kind
turns back on me and I'm the problem so
you really have to know your battles and
pick and choose him because you don't
want to be even if it's a perception
that you're a difficult like every time
we have a know is this writer gonna be
you know fighting us know on the ones
that I really have to fight I will fight
and I think that they will appreciate
that that you just don't roll over that
you're thinking like you said ask
questions why are we doing this and a
lot of times no one knows the script
like the writer because you've lived and
breathed every character and everything
and it's easy just to say we'll make
that change because they're looking at
bigger picture things not the the
details and you have to be the one
they're going hope you know this might
not be a good idea because of this and
they're like oh and then you convince
them
oh yeah you're right I think that's
better where they go this writer you
know is he's a collaborator it's not
gonna be a like a scribe and go yes sir
why yes man whatever you'd like you know
it's a fine line you don't want to fight
your I pick and choose wisely was your
path to becoming a professional
screenwriter the path that you thought
it was going to be going back to even
before you applied for film school yes
and just the vision of whatever it was
yes in your old seeing this is where I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be the next
Cassavetes or whatever yeah and then you
know time moves on and and was it was it
in line with that you know because
people think it's going to be this no
it's never will be MW no it's the
romanticized image no and then it's more
of a craftsperson job it's a career but
I look at it as a job it is my job
and I'm blessed to have the job and I'm
blessed to be working I really like to
work and I take as much work as I can
and turn down things that I don't like
or can't do
but it's nice to be in a place where
producer calls you and says are you
available I've also been in a place
where you turn in your thing and go am I
good enough you know and you wait and
they say and they six months later oh I
didn't read it yet you know I mean which
is the norm so whatever level of the
business you're working at to be have
any type of success I've also realized
is an amazing thing it's hard and many
people can look down at you unless
you're the highest echelon at the a-list
and say well if you're not that then I'm
not impressed by what you do it's like
okay I get it you've never really
struggled to get one thing made so you
wouldn't say that to someone who's been
slogging away the the 10 year overnight
success like I said it was six years out
of film school six years before I had my
first professional job that I was later
fired from quickly you know and then
seven years from my spec to go through
all the wrong people and and the respect
almost won the nickel fellowship and all
these adventures with that one speck now
I wrote other ones right but but it for
it to finally end up you know me sitting
on the set first day of filming going
wow this has been seven years
you know and every every script and
project has its own journey but sure out
of film school I thought that they were
gonna hand us you know our diploma and
our three picture deal which is the joke
where you just bill of course I'll be
working you know and maybe is a PA which
I never did because I didn't want to you
know I knew how to make films I didn't
want to spend 18 hours a day not writing
so I worked in restaurants as a waiter
because then I could always write you
know that's you know I mean going
through college but then you settle into
a place where you finally are at
whatever level you are and have the
players that you are hired you know the
people that you know and do I still want
to get to higher levels absolutely but
no one can take away my ability to write
and create projects you know so that's
the thing so the next step for me would
to be moving into more of a producing
aspect directing I've enjoyed but I
don't I would probably pursued it out of
film school you know and I really like
the fact that as a writer you can go
anywhere like I mentioned I was in Italy
last year for six weeks and I was
writing a screenplay so if you have a
laptop an internet connection you know
you could write anywhere but a director
needs a film crew and a big you know I
have some friends who work two years on
a movie directing it you know I mean
from beginning to end I mean that's a
big big endeavor and I like the fact of
of being able to be mobile you know and
work and maybe do more you know this
last year I've had six movies written
you know so I mean it's it's I couldn't
direct six movies I don't think in here
yeah it's so expensive
yeah to it that's that's a great thing
about the writing is that even though
sometimes they're underappreciated it's
the heartbeat of the movie and it's it's
you know gonna be on vacation or you can
be doing something else and yeah righty
but in terms of like you grew up in
Southern California I did so I wonder
does that taint people and not in a bad
way
but I mean in terms of the vision of
what a career looks like versus someone
that's
you know yeah in another state it's
weird because in some ways it never
seems such a weird when when my friend
and I were making movies as a kid it
never seemed such a weird thing that we
were filmmakers because they were
filming movies on our block you know
outside the biggest TV shows were right
up the block you know and in Santa
Monica they used to film everything
there and so we were like oh now if I
was living in a small city somewhere it
might be so impressive like oh or I
could never be a film because it's so
such a big enormous dream it was right
outside our front door so we were like
huh okay in a good way or bad because
you don't know if you're ever gonna be
able to do it you know and achieve a
career and sustain that so it has I
think the wide-eyed dreamer is still
inside and I need that as a kid but then
you grow up and you realize the
realities of a business you know
filmmaking is is a craft and it's it's
you know but it's a business you know no
one wants to spend millions of dollars
and lose their money on your idea you
know what I mean it's a business
unfortunately but if you can work in it
and keep you know as an artist and and
some are blessed to be an artiste you
know not tour and others are people who
get to work you know and you know if I'm
working in the film business I'm a happy
person you know you think you realize
the amount of time spent alone at a
computer at a desk I mean I realize you
could be in a cafe writing sure and for
a lot of people that does work but do
you think that you realize the and and
and being bound by this calendar the
calendar that said okay this is do and I
need this done by this date and I can't
deviate from that and you have a you
know in school or college you have a
report or whatever do you know there's
there's due dates for everything but
that that made it seem more like a job
which in in the past it was a
romanticized like oh my specs I'll sell
it and there'll be some weird thing that
happens where you won't have to work so
hard because you did the work right you
sold the spec with all the rewrites and
all the possibilities that could happen
then when you start working in the
business you realize all the
possibilities that do happen
and you're like oh wow it sort of knocks
down the shimmer of this romanticized
you know driving with this you know I
had a convertible at one time no it was
a 1964 Buick which is beautiful and I
would drive up the coast but I was like
you know there's you know driving on the
lot and all this stuff that you dream of
you know but then you still have to do
the work mm-hmm and like I said I worked
with a lot of actors back in the
restaurant days who didn't want to do
the work they loved you know I'm an
actor you know brooding in this are you
taking classes well no and went on this
audition cuz I have a good look you're
like oh so you just don't want to do the
work you know or you think it's that
easy so yeah it's it's changed I think
the perception I think once you work in
something we have this outside
perception that many people might have
how oh how amazing it is to be a writer
you're like it is but as a writer take
the Hollywood element out it's it's you
know it's a grind you got to write you
know you got to come up with stuff all
35 scripts I think about I go how did I
channel that many stories through this
body into these things I mean then I go
there won't be any others in the well
how could there be well that's your job
as a writer right to come up with
another story to come up with another
you know I mean that's the beautiful
part about going back to the well and
having it be full of stuff and that's
where you're living comes into play your
experiences and living in an authentic
life where you're always like observing
and doing things because it's your
homework as a screenwriter to do that
because you don't want to go back to
your well and have it be empty that's
when it's vents when you have your
passion dries up and you're like I got
nothing to say I got what am i doing you
know and you you shrink and you just
disappear you know so I think also while
you're trying to pursue your career you
have to live a an interesting life and
do things that are interesting and meet
interesting people and you know have it
all relate back to your screenwriting
because it does it's your job to live an
interesting authentic life and I think
that helps your work